the top Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee says he believes
President Trump faces the possibility of
going to jail after he leaves office
congressman Adam Schiff told Face the
Nation that court documents released
Friday appeared a link mr. Trump to
campaign finance violations involving
his former personal lawyer Michael Cohen
mr. Trump has accused Cohen of lying to
get a lighter sentence Schiff says the
president could face issues even though
he has not been charged with a crime
my takeaway is there's a very real
prospect that on the day Donald Trump
leaves office the Justice Department may
indict him that he may be the first
president in quite some time to face the
real prospect of jail time we have been
discussing the issue of pardons that the
president may offer to people are
dangling in front of people the bigger
pardon question may come down the road
as the next president has to determine
whether departed Donald Trump face the
nation moderator Margaret Brennan joins
us from Washington good morning Margaret
good morning to you Nora it was
interesting to hear the congressman talk
about that why is he more confident in
an indictment rather than impeachment
well we should say the president hasn't
been charged with any wrongdoing here
but according to Schiff he's pointing to
the filing from federal prosecutors
which outlined that the president direct
direct at these illegal payments during
the campaign to silence these ex
mistresses so the prosecutors are
arguing here that it amounts to the
president conspiring with his attorney
Michael Cohen to break campaign finance
laws to influence the outcome of the
election and that brings criminal
activity a felony right to the
president's door but when he's talking
about impeachment he is putting a
different standard here because it's
essentially illegal and a political
calculation the question is whether the
president intended to violate campaign
finance laws and congressman Schiff says
he needs to see more detail of whether
there is a broader pattern of misconduct
that warrants removal from office and
then they have to make the political
calculation of course of whether it
would actually be successful so what we
heard is that they're moving towards it
margarett let's talk about that chief of
staff certainly one of the plum jobs in
Washington that nobody appears to want
I'm curious about Nick Aires because he
got so far down the road with nickers
nickers nickers only to hear Nick say
thanks but no thanks
how does it get that far down the road
and then what is he looking for in a
chief of staff now Nick Aires has been
such a rising star he has been the vice
president's chief of staff and before
that he did a lot of work for the
Republican Party a lot of fundraising as
well he worked for sonny perdue he
worked for Tim Pawlenty so he is a known
entity and viewed as very much a
politically savvy that's one of the
things that made him attractive here
that is the characteristic that the
president's also looking for in terms of
these other contenders so what he really
needs is someone who can help solidify
support from within his own party on
Capitol Hill Republicans and the
president aren't always on the same page
but he needs that republican-controlled
Senate to be a bulwark against any
impeachment proceedings he needs someone
who can navigate a reelection campaign
and so that's why you're seeing some of
these names out there like congressman
mark meadows like former congressman
Mick Mulvaney who have that kind of
judgment but how could they not know
that Nick was gonna say no to this job
apparently the New York Times reporting
the New York Times reporting that they'd
even drafted a press release now how
could that how could it get this far and
they not know he's gonna say no thanks
well Nick had the Nick Ayers had been
talking about returning to Georgia for
some time he's got triplets he wanted to
get back to more time with his family
he's been saying but in terms of how far
along this got it seems like wishful
thinking the president's own children
had been strong active supporters of him
and it seems he just made the
calculation that this wasn't a job he
wanted ahead of the campaign meantime we
have yet to hear from John Kelly's
Margaret thank you